Waves of immigration,
they have fresh and refreshed America.
You can see it,
you can see this wave of Hispanic
immigration,
refreshing America,
just as the European immigration,
so of the 20th century refreshed
America.
And we have such a tremendous capacity
to take people in and make them
American.
Um,
the American system is so,
um,
is so strong that it is an ease.
It,
it changes it,
it reacts,
but it also,
and it,
it,
it reshapes itself a little bit,
but it's so encompassing and to a
certain extent,
so welcoming.
If you look at the way Americans field,
despite the debate about immigration
these days,
if you look at about the way Americans
feel about,
uh,
bringing people in and being an
American,
uh,
the view is if you come here and want to
be an American,
uh,
and act like an American,
you are an American.
That is certainly not the view in large
parts of the world.
And in many,
many Western countries,
uh,
in the,
in the public.
It's not the view of the public's money.
The.